welcome back to safety blitz it is time
rod for turn the page tuesday team that
may be not so pretty need to flip the
page maybe start reading a new book
whatever the case may be
carson wentz indianapolis colts that's
where we begin what is the page they
need to flip there in indy
well carson wins he had one of the worst
interceptions that i've seen
it was a pick six to elijah mode and i
actually played with his dad but i mean
he's dropping back and he's had it and
he was about to throw it at the running
back's feet and then he said nope i'm
gonna keep it and i'm gonna switch hands
and i'm gonna try to get rid of it with
my left hand you can't do this this is
the old carson wench from the
philadelphia eagles this is not the new
carson wins who had camp come in
and ball out and protecting the football
until the titans game only had one
interception this is
come on carson wench you have to do a
better job of this
protecting the football that's what
their success is going to depend on will
he protect the football jack
yeah it's it's very it's retro
carcinogens right i mean this is just
like a classic this is one of those
classic pics that you defeat you just
feel like you've seen it before in your
mind it's a deja vu type interception
from him
and i think it's it comes a bit when
you're trying to prove people wrong
right like carson wentz right now has
all these naysayers people talking down
on his name and he's got this major chip
on his shoulder he's trying to prove
everybody wrong in this second chapter
that's okay
but what's dangerous about it is you
start doing these superhero plays like
patrick mahomes has had a few of these
superhero plays this year as well when
the reality of his role on the
indianapolis colts is hand that football
off let's get the round run game goal
let's get jonathan taylor going in a big
way let's throw some balls up to michael
pittman go make some plays on the
outside but you're not a game manager
but you're a game manager of sorts
within that offense it's run behind that
big offensive line let's get a few
athletic plays out of wins maybe a few
completions but don't be the guy who
loses them the game and that's been the
case far too often this year for wince
and it was again this weekend
yeah you have a good defense too i mean
we talked to darius leonard you got a
really good defense and they actually
feed off the offense if the offense
doesn't turn the ball over if they run
the football take those shots like you
were talking about the defense can can
hang in there and win you some games
get to our second one this is the one we
were local for the minnesota vikings so
we both picked the vikings and frankly
it's ruined the last 48 hours of my life
just thinking about that pick so we took
the vikings have no clue why they're
going up against the backup quarterback
it felt like one of those ones where you
have to take the vikings like you have
to you just have to believe that at home
sunday night football kirk cousins for
once for once a guy that has an 8 and 16
prime time record hates playing under
the bright lights also that's when you
play the good teams and he's got a bad
history against good teams and he just
folded i thought he was terrible what
pages they turned there in minnesota
well i thought that the offensive
coordinator clint kubiak he was terrible
because he came out slinging the ball
down the first drive it was three shots
down the field three shots down the
fielder if if i'm offensive coordinator
clint kubiak
i'm playing aggressive if i have those
weapons i got a young justin jefferson
this kid can play and you only give him
four targets he has two catches against
those corners
it's crazy to me and i was really just
disappointed
also he has to find some level of
creativity in the offense it's no
creativity it's it's a basic offense if
you're not handing it to dalvin cook
you're quick passing it to these one of
these guys every now and then you take a
shot down the field the screen thing the
screen game which had worked so good for
them all year and even last year
it was non-existent so i just i look at
this and i blame him a lot because with
the talent of level the level of talent
that they have there's no reason why
they shouldn't be airing it out i mean
justin jefferson adam
thielen dalvin cook i mean come on man
this is it's crazy
they should be and they were horrible on
third down like one in 13. horrible on
third down it's it's hard to win
that goes back to play calling as well i
got let's see these are some of their
third downs right here but i thought
cousins was just super inaccurate i mean
there's one right there he just sails
over the guy's head i mean there were
moments where he had open wide receivers
and he was just missing there was
moments where they were calling plays
that you're scratching your head at i
thought they threw a couple of screens
in this game to adam thielen where
you're going he just doesn't quite look
right i don't know if he's fully healthy
or what but he was just sort of
going down he was he wasn't really
fighting for many yards you're kind of
going is that is thielen really the guy
you want to throw a screen to or maybe
that's kj osborne or maybe that's justin
jefferson maybe there's some other
option maybe put dalvin cook out there
and throw him the screen at wide
receiver but thielen in this game didn't
look completely right to me
after the catch and i thought it was
interesting to your points rodney i
don't know if you saw thelen's agent but
he was sounding off on twitter saying
basically everything you're saying it's
time this is obscene we need to move on
i'm paraphrasing but he had some very
aggressive tweets talking about really
subtweeting that coaching staff and
we'll see what happens as far as who's
calling the plays moving forward
and absolutely and on the other side i'm
looking at mike zimmer and like
you got a young quarterback okay he
doesn't have a lot of experience he's
not a rookie but he's a young
quarterback
and mike zimmer i remember mike zimmer
and his creativity on defense i used to
admire to do like oh my goodness when i
become a defensive coordinator i want to
call calls like him because he used to
be so creative and so aggressive then
all of a sudden i know he has daniel
hunter i know he has everson griffin but
they're rushing four dropping back
playing conservative defense and you got
cooper rush who hadn't even seen a bunch
of different looks throw man throw the
kitchen sink at him
six-man pressure seven-man pressure zone
pressures corner pressures do whatever
you have to do to confuse this young man
but you can't let him come to the line
of scrimmage and see that harrison smith
and xavier woods are back there playing
cover two and he knows exactly where he
wants to go it was crazy zimmer has to
do a better job not just as a defensive
coordinator but total as a team as a as
a as a team because he's the one that
hired clint kubiak and his offense looks
terrible it looks terrible
in the one time he did bring that
creative blitz you're talking about
xavier woods got that free shot at
cooper rush yep sack fumble and it was
the play i mean they should have been
able to go get points on that drive and
they were still unable to do anything
offensively so i'm right there with you
man and they better be careful right now
because coach zemer he's been there a
long time at some point they got to
start winning games and my guess is it
has to be this stretch to end this year
or else there's going to be some serious
moves made there in minnesota we'll take
a break come back for third and short
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports